hello and welcome to video harder I
can't stand this anymore really every
game be three ok I usually go if I've
and try to punish him but this is the
end of a long session here there's a fun
game for this session I already played a
bad session there and i can i'll just
play normal looking moves and see what
he's doing I think black is usually try
to play this delay tranquilo him Bishop
F a g6 and so on I just try to be quick
here check
yeah maybe d5 him it is working at some
point that I really cannot be bothered
to thinking wrong I just go I just go
play quick museum in this game so what's
this maybe something like the same and
it looks it looks at Ted shaky md5 could
be could be an issue not even add on the
clock for that for that weird position
anyway we'll see what is coming up with
it still should be kind kind of solid
the group we should just um no not here
I wanted to go Bishop g7 but not now
okay
Jim if it treats pieces I'm starting to
feel more comfortable him
trading minor pieces is always a good
thing against the not always yeah it's
it's tough to talk about always in chess
but in most cases trading off my the
pieces has a good good idea again saying
pawns especially the sea pawn could
become can easily become a weekend or
the deep on okay so step to move already
know it's probably a bit of bit too
strong strong medicine 93 is annoying
them taking c4 again their pods are
mostly weekend Bishop ticks ticks with a
king ok king f2 was a good in class hmm
shame I mean as I said in general I'm
happy with those trades but I still
hoped for more
yeah it's comfortable here for black but
I don't have a clear way clear way
forward let's get some doubling on okay
yeah i just think this is week actually
this pawn is just week on c6
you
will advance the bring the king up next
it's not that easy to get to the pawn
actually I mean it's never going
anywhere but oh thanks that that I was
surprised surprised about that looks
kind of a kind of nice now can somehow
regroup to guindos I don't check see it
at the moment okay maybe it's simple
movement will be 54 would be six and
then take it
no maybe that was best I don't know if
you have this is this is something that
you can try just switch form switch for
the ape on now I would definitely be so
quite solid
I'm not trying too hard you okay
it doesn't make any sense hmm well it's
probably just not possible to to do
something serious here especially after
I've allowed g5 that was wasn't a very
successful idea just not not much or
nothing basically mmm two rooks can do
something with two rocks in some kind of
attack or something but probably not I
don't know
check
that's actually a pretty bad idea time
morning check check check rah however
this is that I really don't like to plan
this for Chrome hello you didn't accept
my draw ok corral Shepherd ok yeah then
I went on time I'm sorry I offered twice
I mean white for a fence on time I
offered twice and he refused two times
and I'm going to win this what can I do
now I didn't really didn't get the best
out of that yeah it's kind of nice but I
didn't didn't didn't really kill this g
five wins yeah probably and this look
nice but Kiev to was just holding on and
then he played this this in my book
weird c6 when when it's just a weakness
but it's probably not the end of the
world so okay rook da ting d6 and this
wins the porn okay yeah i'm just not
playing precisely that is the problem a
six is also better than this and here
you can draw with the way you played I
guess okay six I just win the porn there
i'm just playing where I'm just playing
ballet yeah I'm not saying I'm winning
this position but
at least I'm getting the pawn and the
way it went it was just a drawing check
check no no it's twice I mean this is
all that I can all that I can do I mean
you can even if even the draug I itself
you can debate about many many people
things seem to think you can just win
this on time if he has such a bad time
management let's still like to offer
drawers there and I did it twice that's
really all I do okay well thanks for
watching